we can go live to south london where we
can talk to john burko former speaker
of the house of commons he's also a
personal friend of nancy pelosi a very
good afternoon
to you mr burko um you are somebody who
has been
responsible for some ceremony and
sanctity
of office what did you make of the
events
shocked and disgusted the chorus of
execration
samantha of the rioters and
most notably of donald trump's
manifest incitement of them has been
loud it's been eloquent and it's been
justified
and of course also it has been global
right across
the world people have been disgusted by
what they've witnessed there can i think
the absolutely no conceivable doubt
whatsoever
that donald trump has been the author
of his current misfortunes the notion
that somehow he can elide out of this
situation
and convey the impression that it wasn't
his fault it was nothing to do with him
that it's all the misdeeds of others is
frankly
ludicrous it's an insult to people's
intelligence he must have known
that he was lighting the touch paper in
speaking of that rally
in the tones that he did and exhorting
people to march on the capital
it must have occurred to him that
violence
could follow so as far as i am concerned
his sudden change of tone
is completely unconvincing you cannot
believe a word that this big mouth thug
says he's displaced himself he's
disgraced his office he's disgraced
american democracy
and he will either to be summarily
removed as a result of the
application of amendment 25 before the
20th of january
failing that he should be impeached and
i very much hope in the interest of the
united states and of democratic
principles
that one or other of those courses of
action will now follow
yeah i mean your friend i was just
saying there that you're friends with
nancy pelosi she wants to impeach him
not for the first time um
seems to be gathering a bit of momentum
do do you think that uh do you think it
will happen
look i'm not an expert on the operation
of the american system so
you know i should speak with a degree of
humility on the matter
aliens she knows what she's doing she
knows that she will have
bipartisan support and i very much hope
that
if he isn't removed before the twentieth
church seems to me to be
very much a sort of third best option
and a pretty poor
option i've got the highest regard for
nancy pelosi she seems to me to embody
and epitomize
the very best of the american political
system
she's a democrat not just with a large d
but with a
small d she believes in pluralism she
believes in human rights
and she believes samantha very
importantly in respect
the trouble with donald trump who is if
you will a proto-fascist
is that he has absolutely no regard for
or tolerance of any opinion
other than his own he is the ultimate
narcissist he is completely
self-obsessed
it's all about him and frankly i think
the international community is sick and
tired
of him you cannot believe but
john you say that i mean
there's been a lot of talk about the
enablers of president trump and
and it's not just you know the obvious
suspects like ted cruz and mitch
mcconnell mike pence and so on
um we also need to look at don't we uh
you know
there's nigel farage here people can
also say uh our own prime minister boris
johnson and the one before him theresa
may
well look i'm pleased that the prime
minister boris johnson
criticized president trump yesterday i
think he was rather late in doing so but
i welcome the fact that he
robustly did so but you're absolutely
right there have been a lot of
facilitators and enablers
over a long period i thought it was a
great mistake for
prime minister theresa may to rush to
pay homage to donald trump
back in 2017 she was itching to invite
him to
the united kingdom to speak to the
british parliament something about which
i was consulted into which i
very strongly objected and in the end
that attempted ingratiation with
president trump
didn't work for very long as soon as
theresa may called him out
for retweeting fascist material he
turned on her
and okay her efforts on brexit were not
fruitful
that he then conducted a running
commentary on her efforts and
undermined her and of course jacob
rees-mogg the conservative mp and now
leader of the house
said years ago that if he were an
american citizen he would vote for
donald trump i could go the british
cabinet minister rush to
interview donald trump nigel farage has
paid homage to him and in 2018 boris
johnson said that he thought that
donald trump was a suitable potential
contender
for the nobel peace prize so all of
these people i'm afraid
have sucked up to and sought to
ingratiate themselves with somebody
who simply doesn't respect democratic
principles
but we can't forget can we that more
than 70 million people in america voted
for him
yes i have to acknowledge that he won
the election in 2016 legitimately i've
never said
otherwise he won the electoral college
and you make a fair point there
and it is a shocking fact in polling
undertaken i think only yesterday by
yougov
that 45 of republican voters
think that the storming of the capital
was justified so yes he does have very
considerable public support
in the united states minority support
and he lost the election by seven
million votes and he also have the
decency and respect and good grace to
acknowledge the bible harris victory
which of course he doesn't do because he
doesn't know the meaning of the word
respect yes he does have widespread
support but he
has minority support and he adheres to
and practices the wrong values
he's racist he's sexist he has no
respect for anybody else he's a totally
unsuitable public servant
and i think that one of the merits of
impeachment would be that frankly he
couldn't stand for
public office again and that would be
very much in the interest of the united
states he ought to well
perhaps not perhaps perhaps not for the
70 million people who voted for him
they wouldn't be happy to see that um
let's move on
uh 12 days time a new incumbent
in the white house joe biden uh how does
he go about getting uh
dare i ask the man himself order
well of course it's for the speaker of
the
house to get order in the legislature
and indeed the speaker of the senate for
that matter and i'm
sure they will do their jobs
fantastically i've already made it clear
i'm a huge and
unalloyed admirer of nancy pelosi who
represents the very best of american
politics as far as joe biden is
concerned
look he has the wind in his sails he has
the democratic legitimacy of being
elected
and being elected by an enormous margin
and i think the success
of the democrats in the runoff races
in georgia has fortified him further so
he's got
a relatively free hand he might like to
have a bigger majority but he's got
majority control
of both houses of congress he's got the
public support
he's a long-standing and thoroughly
decent public servant who has
spoken with enormous dignity and
conviction
in recent days and i think people around
the world will say
thank goodness there's going to be a
change and
it's biden harris not trump pence
this is good news for the united states
it's good news for relations
with the uk and with europe and for the
conduct of american diplomacy
around the world so i don't know jerry
biden personally
but i admire him and i wish him and the
vice president
every possible success in charting an
altogether more constructive course for
the united states
okay john burko good to talk to you
thanks for your time